we're joined Now by Homeland Security
secretary that's Alejandro mayorcas good
to see you Mr secretary I know you have
a lot going on this morning
good morning thank you for having me
well we just heard speaker McCarthy say
the White House had no plan that you all
have bumbled it and now you've created
another crisis it's no surprise to you
that they don't think you're doing a
good job on this but let's talk about
the numbers it does seem to be
overwhelming sixty thousand migrants
right now are waiting along the border
hoping to enter this country right now
what's being done to address that and
how do you respond to speaker McCarthy
we have had a plan uh for more than a
year and a half we've been executing on
that plan and we continue to execute on
the plan we knew the transition from the
public health authority of title eight
I'm sorry title 42 as we transition to
our traditional immigration authorities
was going to be tough we're ready for
this time how can we tell that it's
working Mr secretary because all we see
is a lot of people at the border trying
to get in
well that is that is a phenomenon by the
way that is not unique to our Southern
border of the United States it's
something we're seeing across the entire
region but I've been very clear that our
plan is going to take some time to show
results and right now we are about what
uh six hours into the end of title 42
the public health authority we're going
to continue to execute our plan to take
individuals into our custody to remove
them very quickly under our immigration
authorities when they don't qualify for
Relief people are going to see our plan
take hold it will take time it will
succeed
Mr secretary I take it face value that
you're doing all you believe you can do
right at this moment and with that up
front I wonder would you describe the
border right now as safe and secure
our border patrol agents are doing an
extraordinary job of making it safe and
secure that's what they do every day of
the week day and night 24 7. what we
need what we need is Congress to act to
pass legislative reform everyone agrees
that our immigration system has been
broken for more than two decades we need
Congress to act we also need Congress to
Resource the Department of Homeland
Security with the Personnel equipment
facilities and transportation ability
that we have requested and we have not
received
Mr secretary I heard you say that you
have a plan in place can you just
briefly describe what the plan is very
briefly and why you're so confident it's
going to work
so let me let me say that our plan is as
follows in just very simple terms we
provide lawful safe and orderly Pathways
for people to come to the United States
when they qualify for Relief we have a
security and a humanitarian obligation
to cut the Smugglers out for those
individuals those people who do not use
are lawful Pathways we have tougher
consequences to deliver to them if they
arrive at our Southern border and cross
illegally all right secretary myarkis we
thank you for your time today we know
you have a lot to do more to come thanks
thank you so much